a unique exercise in participatory
democracy the conference on the future
of Europe saw hundreds of people from
across the EU work in citizens panels to
table recommendations on how to improve
the union seven months on at a feedback
event in Brussels representatives of the
eu's three main institutions answered
questions on how they are acting on the
conferences for cruises this was not a
one-off exercise for the European Union
your proposals are not some checklist
that we need to take to close the door
on the conference on the future of
Europe once and for all
the conference proposed hundreds of
measures on areas ranging from the
environment migration and equality to
rights democracy and the eu's global
role all brought into sharp focus by the
war in Ukraine and Rising living costs
their aim is to make the EU future proof
and to deliver on citizens expectations
what we have seen is the need for social
support
in European Union
due to the crisis the need for an energy
transition for an energy Union if you
look today to the world there is more
reason to implement the conclusions of
the conference thus seven months ago
hundreds of citizens attended the event
their commitment to change and
accountability is still strong I think
we all greatly benefited from this
experience we would like to continue the
cooperation with you we would like to
look forward some kind of formal and
open Communication channel
the conference's proposals form an
important part of parliament's agenda
for 2023.
[Applause]